مشاهدينا قبل ان نخوض في اخبار السياسه
نتوقف عند خبر رحيل اسطوره كره القدم
النجم البرازيلي بالله عن عمر نهز اثنين
وثمانين عاما بعد صراع مع المرض ابنه
النجم بلا اكدت خبر وفاته عبر حساب على
الانستغرام
متمنيه الراحه لروحي والدها
من المستشفى
الجزيره حسن مسعود حسان ما هي المعطيات
المتوفره حتى اللحظه حول هذه الوفاه وحول
مراسم الوداع
نعم حسن قبل ساعه من الان ااا اعلن هذا
الخبر المفجع بالنسبه للبرازيليين والذي
كانوا يترقبونه ويتمنون الا يحدث بالفعل
وهو رحيل اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
اتسن ارنتس دونالدز سمنتو عن عمر نهز 82
عاما هذا الاسطوره الذي يلقب هنا في
البرازيل بالملك ملك كره القدم البرازيليه
الذي استطاع ان يحضر كاس العالم للبرازيل
ثلاث مرات عمى 58 و 62 وعم 70 ولقب همم في
ارشيف الفيف بانه اعظم لاعب في كره القدم
وكذلك حصل على لقب افضل لاعب في القرن
العشرين من قبل اللجنه الاولمبيه رحل
اليوم هنا في هذا المستشفى المستشفى البرت
اينشتاين سنشاهد هذه
صور المباشره الان التي تاتيكم على شاشه
الجزيره
لهذه الاجواء عند الدقائق الاولى بعد رحيل
اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيليه الذي اعلن عن وفاته قبل ساعه
عندما اكدت نجله او ابنه همم الراحل
اسطوره كره القدم
هذا الخبر معلنه همم انه رحل وان كل شيء
نحن فيه كما ذكرت في صورتها في السوره
التي نشرتها هو بفضل هذا الرجل همم هذا
هذه الوفاه اعلنت بعد ما كان قد وصل النجم
بلاي الى هذا المستشفى المستشفى البرت
اينشتاين في باولو قبل شهر من الان في
حاله
الصحافه قد تداولت عنها حاله صعبه واا انه
كان يخضع للعلاج همم
فقط دون اا ال- اا القدره على التجاوب مع
العلاج الكيميائي الذي كان يعالج من خلاله
بسبب اصابته بمرض سرطان القولون هذا المرض
الذي كان قد اصابه في سبتمبر من عام 2021
عندما همم خضع لعمليه جراحيه لاستئصال جزء
من القولون بسبب همم هذا الورم السرطيني
وكان يخضع للعلاج تماثل حينها للشفاء عاد
الى حياته شبه الطبيعيه والتقى بعدد من
محبيه همم في مدينته سانتوس التي همم هي
التي تتحضر الان
لاستقباله وللاقامه همم الجنازه على روحه
في ملعب مدينه سانتوس ملعب النادي الذي
كان قد لعب به نجم الكبير بليه لمده
ثمانيه عشر عاما بشكل فاصل
وحقق فيه اكبر الانجازات في تاريخ هذا
النادي همم كان قد لعب في نادي سانتوس
وعندما كان قد ايه همم
اقترب من الرحيل عن نادي سانتوس عام 58
واجرى عقدا مع نادي انتر ميلان همم
الايطالي قامت ما يشبه به الثوره في مدينه
سانتوس الساحليه في مدينه همم في ولايه
سوفاولو ل همم
رحيل اللاعب والنجم الكبير الراحل بلاي
وعاد الى هذا النادي ليواصل مسيرته
الكرويه هو يعتبر اسطوره كبيره بالنسبه
للبرازيليين وهذا هذه الوفاه اتت قبل
يومين فقط من همم الموعد المحدث لتنصيب
الرئيس البرازيلي المنتخب لولا ده سيلفا
وهو ما يثير الان حاله من الضبابيه حول
مصير هذا التنصيب حول واقع البلاد وموعد
اا الجنازه وكل هذه تفاصيل التي سنتابعكم
وسنفيدكم بها فور صدورها ان شاء الله شكرا
لك حسان مسعود من سوفاوله